the already high tensions in washington
intensified after a driver rammed a
barricade and then opened fire this
happened just a block from the capitol
where there's been a major increase in
threats scott mcfarlane is near the
scene of the crash scott good
morning nate good morning to you this
caused a lot of alarm on capitol hill
which has been increasingly vigilant
about security since january 6 2021.
at this intersection during the pre-dawn
hours police say richard york of
delaware 29 years old crashed his car
into a barricade the car caught fire
then they say he pulled out a gun and
started pulling the trigger the burned
out remnants of his car were the final
remnants at the scene here police say
the initial gunshots didn't hit or hurt
anyone but the police chief says as
officers approached york york shot and
killed himself police say at this point
it doesn't appear york was targeting
members of congress members of congress
aren't here right now they're home for
the august recess
this nevertheless happened at a
particularly tense moment here at the
capitol for congress for the neighboring
community for the police officers it was
last april an attacker crashed into a
barricade and killed a veteran capitol
police officer but also public records
obtained by cbs news show the number of
investigations into threats against
members of congress has increased by
hundreds since january 6 2021 right now
the motive behind this incident is not
clear why this man drove all the way to
the capitol complex tony
it seems to be getting worse scott thank
you very much